went to China we played we playing KD
Stephanie I played the best defense the
hardest defense I ever played in my life
why
I was trying to like I wasn't trying to
get embarrassed you know it's a hundred
thousand people in the stands in China
respect so I'm like he ain't about to
kill me bro I swear to God played so
I've never played this hard see if after
the game came in that's the best defense
I ever played Steph Curry had 44.
yeah every shot bro yeah every shot bro
every time I contest to everyone bro at
one point they start doing that
because we in China I got so much I
messed up there
but me and stepping to each other we was
all Americans and college together yeah
that's my man so we like he like nah see
you got you know you got to be more
personable so people can like you and
like when you make a shot like look
at your hand do some
you make an early shot I only made four